[Applause]
hi everybody
drew's news where we crack open that ice
cold can of refreshing good news and
with me at the desk is a man who really
knows how to relish that first sip it's
rusty russ matthew
hi everybody
all right should we get right into it
right into it
first up we've got the latest in snack
science today it's food news
ross if you could walk down any aisle
with any snack food who would the lucky
snack be yeah this is a very serious
question so i took it very seriously my
gateway food of all foods is
pizza pizza is
like the ex who i broke up with and when
i see them out i'm like oh don't look at
me
oh that's funny because i'm always like
best friends with all my exes and
that's exactly how i feel about
mac and cheese i only have heart eyes
for this and you know sometimes i want
to take it easy on the cheesy but how do
i just say no
well insider reports that science says
you can
resist by using your old snifferoo
researchers at the university of florida
say that if you smell your favorite
snack for two minutes the craving can
disappear and you're basically tricking
your brain into thinking that you ate it
ross we're the guinea pigs today and
you've got a slice of za right in front
of you hello lover hi
all right let's give it a good whiff
okay
oh it does smell like pizza hi
i just want to motorboat it
gosh i don't know
okay well we're just going to keep on
sniffing until the end of the news and
then we'll really ask ourselves but does
anyone think this could work raise your
hands if you think it's like plausible
yeah
i'm finding hands i'm kind of with those
of you with your hands down now i want
pizza more than i have in months i go
now i'm like
girl
as they say bite down just a little bite
i blame you why you got me smelling
pizza up here i don't know but you know
ross it is your story oh wait all right
that has worked out i know you know what
it takes you know what it tastes like
pizza
all right you keep chewing drew and in
the meantime i'll talk about this yahoo
life reports uh olivia wilde and harry
styles who i call wild styles oh
thank you very much we're spotted in l.a
wearing matching outfits
they call it twinning and apparently
it's the new thing
tons of celebs have been known to go
matchy-matchy look at these ones uh brad
pitt twinning through his relationship
history there's remember this with
gwyneth oh my god jen
with angie wow he really does
he really twins i think it's cute i
don't think you should like identically
match like think think when in doubt
think like destiny's child remember how
they were all sort of hausa dairy
uncoordinated but they weren't identical
do that that's cute i i will say
wellington and i my fiance we coordinate
we don't match which i think is less
tacky um well i'm not to cut in on
wellington but you and i coordinate
which i really love yeah
well we do that every day there's so
there's wellington and i we are in
matching velour jumpsuits that i
literally bought at forever 21.
i love that isn't that cute oh i love
that you know you and wellington are
planning your big wedding day as we
speak so i got to get your take on this
next story because this one really does
it for me
all right the new york post reports that
doug and deidra a couple from chicago
recently went viral when they issued an
invoice to all the guests who flaked on
their wedding look at this i'm not
kidding this is real they sent an
official bill and they're charging 120
per person to everyone who said they did
but then they didn't
and they didn't show up in new grill
jamaica for the big day
the couple says they asked for
confirmation four times and none of the
no-shows bothered to write text or call
that they couldn't make it ross
what are your thoughts are you gonna put
invoices into people's boxes who do this
to you uh okay i am planning a wedding
and i don't know if you heard but
they're not cheap but if there were a
no-show at my wedding i'd like to think
that i would send this but i don't think
i i would i think i would just silently
resent you and then slowly cut you out
of my life
i think that's the natural thing to do
but
i kind of get it they should have let
them know they should have let them know
and maybe they had like the best reason
in the entire world i would love to get
to the bottom of this me too which is
why doug and deidre we want to talk oh
that's right
we want to reach out and we wouldn't
find if a guest or two would come on and
talk to us about why they were a no-show
and did they have a reason yes
what's your take on the flake are you
like a hold out do you think this is a
good idea do you
disagree we want to hear about this i
think this is a movement in the making
and it's a little dangerous but it's
also a little dope so
roster
i want them all to come on plead their
case can we get judges robes and then
decide
yes
who's in the right who's in the wrong
i'll pull an rbg okay
all right that's your story stay tuned
everyone okay give me this and then i'll
tell you the story thank you okay you
can take it over here i'm gonna put it
next to my pizza we can
goodbye okay
finally we've got a really touching
story from australia i saw this i showed
drew and we had to tell you all about it
people reports that a farmer named ben
jackson rallied his flock of sheep to
pay tribute to a special family member
his aunt deb recently passed away after
a long battle with cancer and ben
couldn't make it to her funeral because
of covet and travel restrictions so
instead he honored his
incredibly giving ant with a
flock-shaped heart on his land in new
south wales look he made the how do you
teach what how do you do that but it was
so
beautiful and touching what a beautiful
gesture you know i think that was just
lovely ever since
you know this is always the way i love
to kind of end the news because
ross brought this to my attention and i
haven't been able to get the visual out
of my head ever since
and it's something that i can now go to
in moments i can travel to in my mind as
a destination of
peace tranquility and beauty and rossi
always you're the one who taught me this
thank you thank you drew
[Music]